- Hey friend, why don't you join us?
Why don't you come back?
Thank you, oh okay.
Oh okay, goodbye.
(upbeat music)
I had a very interesting time
starring on a reality show
at only the age of eight.
Oh, oh, but I don't think I
would ever do one ever again
just because they're a little stressful
and I'd rather do acting.
I think a transition from
dancing to acting is different
and the same in so many ways,
because when you dance you have to act
and you have to show emotion,
so I think it really
helped me relate to acting.
It's pretty obvious, I have
the biggest crush on Zac Efron.
I've had it since I was five-years-old.
I will always love him till the day I die.
I wish I could marry him, but
he's slightly too old for me.
I would say Zendaya is a
really big inspiration for me
in the fashion world just
because she has so many
amazing looks and it's
different every time.
Sometimes she decides to go
more on the tomboy route,
or sometimes she decides to make it
super girly and glamorous,
so she's definitely a very
big inspiration to me.
I had no clue that
Chandelier would blow up,
let alone have over a billion views,
and it was probably the best
experience and day of my life
when that video released,
just because ever since then
it's just been a whirlwind for me.
To make sure I love
everything that I'm doing,
and to always remember
that I'm still a child,
and to never take anything too far
so that I'm not overworked.
She plays really old
music and she'll dress up,
and she'll impersonate all
of my dances that I did
when I used to compete.
She was the biggest fan of Dance Moms
and she knows more of it than I do,
so it's really, really funny.
Less is more.
When you're wearing too much makeup,
I feel like you can look cakey.
Oh it's okay, you can eat my hair,
I don't really mind.
I don't know exactly what
I'll be doing in 20 years.
I think I would love to
continue acting and dancing.
Maybe choreograph some things,
do a lot more music videos with Sia,
and continue to feature
in a bunch of films.
Hey, a dog toy.
Oh, that one just slipped through my legs.
Okay.
You're so adorable, can you say bye?
Bye.